"YES, your site too can (and should) be accessible.
Lessons learned from building FT.com"
Laura Carvajal
LAURA: Good morning, everyone.
I was in the audience for a talk on accessibility
a few years back much like you are right now,
and I was sitting with some colleagues from
a previous job and I remember feeling stuff
like, well, this is really nice, really cool,
but does it really apply to the thing that
I'm building?
I was working on a mobile site at a time and
I kept hearing about all this keyboard stuff
that I had to look into.
So that didn't really matter to me.
And I thought, well, maybe we were starting
a new project, so it felt, like, there was
this huge gap between the thing that I was
building and accessibility.
And looking back, I'm honestly a little bit
embarrassed to admit this, but I also like
to full own having been there because it helps
me appreciate just how easy it is to feel
that way, and just how far accessibility can
be from the thing that you're doing.
So fast forward to 2016, I was working at
the Financial Times, we were building the
fastest, greatest new site out there.
We released that October.
We replaced our old monolithic website and
it was a great success.
We were winning all these awards.
We were excelling at performance, security.
So basically every metric that we set out
to excel at, we were.
So one thing we decided to look at was accessibility,
thinking, well, we're great at all these things,
maybe we're great at accessibility, too, just
magically.
But unlike performance and security, we hadn't
really put a collective effort into accessibility
so no surprise, we weren't very good.
And well, since this talk is about the lessons
we learned, that was really our first lesson.
Accessibility doesn't just happen; you have
to make it happen.
So my name is Laura Carahal.
And I work at the Financial Times.
And today I want to tell you about the lessons
we learned once we realized we had built this
beautiful performant thing that couldn't really
be used by everyone.
And so today, if you're in that clays you're
wondering if accessibility applies to your
project, I hope you walk away convinced that
it does and that's really easy to get started.
So what is accessibility?
Many definition out there but there's one
that I really, really like because it strips
it down to its core.
It says: Web accessibility means that people
with disabilities can use the web.
That's it.
It just boils it down to not denying anyone
access to the thing that you're building.
To go beyond this a little bit, I want to
tell you a quick story.
I was in that shopping mall with my daughter
a few weeks back.
It's a modern shopping mall in London, Wimbley,
and we were going down that escalator down
there.
And she asked me, while we were going up,
how does someone in a wheelchair get to do
what we're doing?
And I told her, there's an elevator somewhere,
and as we're going up, she says, where is
it?
And to be honest, I couldn't see it.
It was only when we got to the top, that I
could see at the very long end of that hallway,
I pointed it out.
And she said, well, a person in a wheelchair
would have to go all the way there, and back,
that's not fair.
And children have a way of seeing things for
the way they are.
And so even though I explained regulations
and minimum things that you have to comply
with, she was totally not buying it, it was
not fair.
And that's the truth.
I mean, this was a modern building that met
all the requirements but you had that unfair
situation there.
So I'd like to say that accessibility goes
beyond not denying access; it's about ensuring
that the access that you provide is fair for
everyone and I'm giving my daughter full credit
for that quote.
So we've covered what accessibility is.
In terms of disability, it can be divided
into four categories: Physical, visual, hearing,
or cognitive.
These could be permanent disabilities but
we also have temporary and situational disabilities.
So, for example, if a permanent disability
is deaf and hard of hearing, a temporary disability
could be, in the dotted orange box there,
having an inner ear infection.
So for a period of time, you can't hear very
well, or a situational disability is, you're
in a noisy place, and you can't hear things
because there's noise preventing you from
hearing.
So we designed something for someone deaf
in mind by adding, for example, closed captioning
to your videos, that benefits anyone else
that falls anywhere on that spectrum.
So getting back to permanent disabilities,
as far as permanent disabilities go, there's
about 1 billion people in the world with disabilities,
and when you factor in your own userbase and
their demographics, you can get a clearer
picture of what that number looks like for
your business.
So we did that at the Financial Times and
that worked out to be about 20% of our users
because when you factor in the age distribution
of our readership, that tends to skew a little
bit older.
So we got a higher number there.
So if you're anything like the FD, they have
a wide audience, consuming the products and
the services that you put out.
You probably go through great lengths, too,
to support all the members of that audience.
So, for example, you have people on IE 8 and
that only makes up about 5% of your userbase,
you're probably making sure that they get
a good experience, or at least an acceptable
experience so all of a sudden, we have about
20% of our userbase that we're ignoring.
And that tends to get things moving.
So that's a good motivation to get things
started.
So let's say I've convinced you now and you
were gonna do this.
You're determined to get accessibility into
your project, and it's hard, and it's overwhelming,
and you don't really know where to start.
Our suggestion is to just start small.
For us, starting small meant doing that.
We installed pa11y into our project.
Pa11y is an open source tool that will check
your markup against some regulations I'll
show you in a little bit and it can detect
some accessibility errors.
It doesn't detect everything but it's a good
place to start.
There are other open source tools that do
the same thing but we've found pa11y to be
a great thing for our project, and it has
a great community of members and developers
around it.
So this was the way that we started.
So the way pa11y works is it goes through
the web content accessibility guidelines.
We won't go very deep into this today but
you can go and check it out.
It's a list of criteria that your site should
meet if it is to be accessible.
So it checks your markup against that, and
then it gives you a report of what's broken.
And so we ran pa11y against ft.com, and we
got a whole list of errors that was a lot
more than two at the time.
And at that moment, we could just go and fix
the errors, and run this every now and then
manually, and then fix things that come up,
but unless we had something that we could
automate into our build process, this wasn't
going to be very efficient.
So pa11y has sort of a wrapper that's called
pa11y-ci, that just helps you to wrap pa11y
into your continual process.
So this is what we did in FT.
This is an overall simplified version of our
Node process.
So one app would be the opportunity page,
or the article page, or sign-up pages.
And those apps live on GitHub.
Every time we push to a branch in GitHub,
that kicks off a CircleCI build, and if it's
a master branch, then it goes to Heroku and
it's off to production.
So pa11y kicks in here, in the continuous
integration step.
So it would run for every push for every branch
for your project and it would tell you what
accessibility errors you have.
So to do that, we just need it to add one
line to our existing build process which is
.make pa11y.
And really, what that does is run pa11y-ci
and it's highly customizable.
And so in our case, every branch generates
a dynamic app with a dynamic name and so we
run pa11y-ci against that.
And the interesting thing here is the threshold
amount.
So, at the time, we've had dozens of apps
making up ft.com and we had hundreds of errors.
So we couldn't just, one day, break every
build, and hold production and say, hey, we
need to fix all these errors.
So what that allows you to do is integrate
pa11y to not break your builds, and so your
builds will pass.
So you initially set that value to something
very high.
You'll still have builds pass, and no one
will have builds failing because of it.
But you'll have a report now of the accessibility
errors that you have.
So once we did that, we went, app-by-app,
cleaning up the errors, and then we would
remove the threshold argument.
So for that moment, if a new branch included
a new accessibility error, then that branch
wouldn't pass.
And so that was sort of our ultimate goal.
So it would look like that.
So now you've reached kind of like a zero-error
level, and now that has a new branch, it has
a new error and you can't push that to production.
So that was a big achievement and we were
getting to the point where all of our apps
had this.
They all had zero errors and they were preventing
making new errors into production.
And that was a big deal.
We felt like winners.
No accessibility errors would ever make it
to production.
But we realized that even though everyone
was for accessibility, they all liked the
idea of pa11y, they even liked having the
idea of having pa11y break their build.
We didn't really do a great job of explaining
what once you got that list of errors, or
what that meant, or what you were supposed
to do.
So that was a lesson learned.
So before you set a project on fire, train
people.
So a good place to start is this free Udacity
course.
But this is a great tutorial that you can
at your own pace and this is where we started
our own training.
So we've reached that level where you have
zero errors in your app, or in all your apps.
You've removed that threshold argument and
nothing's going to make it into production.
So now we've talked about errors that you
can detect automatically in pa11y.
So that's about 20-35% of all the errors that
you can and at least needs to be checked manually.
And so to do that is you can do some things.
One of them is getting an external audit where
a third party with experience in accessibility
checks your site and tells you -- gives you
a report of what's broken, or certifies you
that you have no errors and that you are accessible.
Something else that you can do is have customer
research or do user testing and the third
one is learning how to use assistive tech
yourself so you can test your own site and
spot some of these errors.
These are not mutually exclusive, and ideally
you should be doing all of them.
So I'm going to go through each of these.
In our case, the external audit was conducted
by the Digital Accessibility Center, and I'm
going to show you a little video of what they
did.
>> My name is Jebec Morgan, and I have cerebral
palsy.
>> Choose three.
>> Click button.
>> It controls the videos.
>> My name is James Herkain, and I'm the color
contrast and disability analyst at --
>> On the home page, I encountered some text
displayed on top of images.
Text displayed on top of images could be very
difficult to read because of the varying contrast.
>> I'm a web analyst at DOC.
I test zoom test with audible feedback.
And I'm going to scroll down below and just
test this.
>> My opinion, Morgan's companies, world,
home.
>> So there's an empty space here which would
be an ideal place to put the subheading.
>> My name is Charles Brew, and I'm at -- there's
a moving image that extracts me from all the
content.
Another issue that I've found on the home
page is the carousel.
When navigating through it, I couldn't find
the arrow to navigate to each page.
And once I found that, eventually finding
the other previous button was difficult.
>> Hello there, my name is Mike Jones and
I'm completely blind and I'm an accessibility
analyst at the Digital Accessibility Center.
On one of the articles that I've tested, there
were several headings that announces read
more.
And these also interrupt the article.
It's not clear what the user should be reading
more about.
Actually these headings interrupt the main
article that the user is reading.
So it would have been helpful to me, to ensure
that the article read smoothly and continuously
without interruptions.
LAURA: Yeah, so that's some of the work that
they did.
This is only two minutes long but I was lucky
enough to be able to spend a day -- a full
day -- with them while they were doing the
testing.
And if you have a chance to do this for the
product that you're building, I highly recommend
it because it will change your perspective
on the work that you do forever.
So after that, all of that testing, we got
a report back with about -- it was, like,
a 200-page report giving us all the errors
that we had -- all the stuff that they had
to detect manually.
So we went about fixing all of those.
It took us a couple of months.
And just very recently we got an accreditation
saying that this website is accessible to
this level of conformance and we were very
glad to get it because it was very hard work
and we were also very glad to be the first
site in our industry to get it, but this is
not a title that we want to hold alone.
So we encourage people from The Guardian,
and The Post, and The Times, to get on this
because this is one metric that we should
all be trying to outdo each other on.
So another problem is customer research.
But if you want your new features to make
sense, they should probably be tested by actual
users, or you could end up, you know, building
something that looks good on paper but still
get it very, very wrong.
So lastly, here I wanted to talk a little
bit about how we went about learning how to
use assistive tech ourselves.
We had never done that before as a team.
So this is one thing that you can do for free
and I would highly encourage it.
This is some of the tools we use.
You can get them all for free if you have
a Mac.
We used VoiceOver for screenreader.
And we used the zoom capabilities of the Mac.
We tested a little bit on Windows as well
because they have this high-contrast mode
that just breaks everything.
So it's a lot worse than the Mac one, and
by worse I mean a lot better because it finds
more errors so if you have access to Windows,
I would highly recommend looking at what you're
looking at with that build on that mode.
So one thing that really helped us a lot was
testing keyboard only.
So initially we would just go to ft.com and
just test the site using the keyboard and
then go about our lives and using our mouse,
or our trackpad.
But what really made a difference was going
keyboard only all the time.
So one thing you learn is you can use keyboard
only on sites because they are good with keyboard
accessibility.
But there are some sites that are impossible
to use, and that becomes evident very quickly
once you give up your house or your trackpad.
So to be able to make the transition easier
from using a trackpad, to a keyboard is by
using mouse keys.
So what that can do is disable your trackpad
but it gives you the possibility to control
your pointer with your number keys.
So you can use that in an emergency.
So if you have a site that has particularly
bad accessibility, and you don't have a mouse,
instead of using the mouse or a trackpad,
you can -- so it's really annoying.
And really only want to use it when there's
no other way.
So one thing we realize is convenient before
you go keyboard only is printing out some
of the shortcuts for your top apps.
This was my setup around November.
But once you do this for a while, and you
just memorize the shortcuts by using them,
and all that paper goes away.
Sometimes I don't have an external keyboard
when I take my laptop home, for example.
So what I've done is I've made my trackpad
really, really slow and I've removed all the
goodies that Apple gave me so that when I
do have to use it, it's uncomfortable so it
reminds me to go back and use the keyboard.
So that's lesson number three: Throw away
your mouse.
So going back to that list of things that
you have to fix, you've learned to use all
these tools.
You have your keyboard set up.
It's really tempting to just roll up your
sleeves and try to fix everything yourself,
but if you're building a large site, I'd recommend
you don't do that.
So it's -- wait, let's go back to Jim Carrey
for a minute.
So one thing that we learned -- or that I
learned -- it wasn't that quickly, it took
a while, was that if you try and take on everything
yourself, it's not efficient, it's not the
right answer.
You end up burning out, errors keep coming
back in faster than you can clean it up and
you really do a disservice to your team by
becoming a bottleneck.
So what you can do here is just get everyone
involved.
A lot of people -- almost everyone -- everyone
I know really wants to be a part of this,
and wants to help, and they can only do that
if you let them know that you need to help,
that you're doing this, and how they can help.
Just give them tools to do this.
So if you do have some time, just spend some
of it training your team and getting them
involved rather than just trying to fix everything
yourself.
Also make it part of your recruitment process
if you can.
Make it part of your job description, of your
online tests, just put it out there.
So that was lesson number four for us: Don't
take it all out on yourself.
Another good way to spread the word is making
an event out of it.
We put together a road show in the office
where we set some laptops in the middle of
the office and we invited everyone to just
try to complete a form using a screenreader.
And we offered an Amazon gift card as a prize.
So it was, like, a $20 Amazon gift card but
people love Amazon so everyone stopped by.
So this was a form that you had to fill out.
So you can't really easy that much, and you're
forced on using the screenreader to do it.
And a lot of people who stopped by, this was
the first time of of them using a screenreader.
Some of them didn't even know what a screenreader
was.
So this was a great way to expose a lot of
people at the same time to accessibility.
So that's what the form is.
It's a very simple form with some annoying
menu items if you don't skip them properly.
And it had some accessibility built in.
And the way that we did that was just very
crudely blurred things, and disabling clicks,
and discouraging people, saying not to cheat.
But this event that we held was probably a
highlight in my 15 years of doing this.
Is this moment.
That's Patrick Hammond, you probably know
him, a seasoned developer, and Patrick, I
apologize, I'm going to use that for the rest
of the year as I talk about this.
We got that type of reaction from a lot of
people, and it was really great because we
managed to create a space of collective empathy
within these 20 minutes or so that people
did this.
We had all these people just stepping into
someone else's shoes for a minute or two at
a time but everyone walked away with a new
perspective on how people really use the product
that they were building.
So that was lesson number five: Talk about
it a lot.
Make sure you spread the word.
You never know who's listening and you're
probably inspiring more people than you think
you are.
Before we finish, I wanted to take you back
to how they really all got started for us
at the FT.
I was in book duty one day and I noticed this
card on our JIRA board for bug duty.
Bug duty is the only place on our JIRA board.
It said integrate pa11y.
I didn't know what pa11y was.
And when I picked up that card expect and
when saw the card, I noticed that it had been
sitting around for a long time, I saw that
Ben Fletcher created it.
And he's a developer who's deaf-blind and
he just made us aware that that is something
that we should be looking at.
So that's the next point, diversity will improve
the team, it will improve you.
Ben's actions really snowballed into us building
a better product.
Our team learned about accessibility and got
a new perspective, and just grew as a team.
And it led to me standing in front of you
all here today.
So to recap, just the things that you learned,
and probably some things that you can do tonight
in half an hour.
Accessibility doesn't just happen.
You can do that in one minute in your project,
if you make pa11y-ci as a part of your build
process with a high threshold, and start getting
reports of your accessibility errors.
Number two, train your people.
One good way is you could share that Udacity
course with your colleagues, that's very quick.
Throw away your mouse but I do suggest printing
out shortcuts beforehand.
Don't throw it to yourself.
Get people, get designers, QA, get product
involved.
Talk about it.
Go on Twitter.
There's a lot of fantastic people out there
with great insights on accessibility.
I'll share some links at the end of this talk.
So, yeah, just go over the Twitter feeds and
see what they're talking about.
Retweet that you find interesting, something
that inspires you.
That can be done very quickly.
And the last one, I unfortunately, don't have
a magic silver bullet but you can do it in
30 seconds in your work.
But if you're involved in hiring, try to prioritize
it, and if not, make it a thing that you talk
about it, but it really benefits all those
things that we just talked about.
A while back, it was probably normal to have
this be the only entrance to a public building
somewhere.
Now it would be unthinkable to have this.
But don't wait until it becomes unthinkable
to have inaccessible websites.
The time to make your website accessible is
today.
So just do it.
Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
That was an excellent talk on why accessibility
is so important.
Also how blind we are to how other people
might be using the web.
It's a super important space to work in and,
yeah, thank you, again, to Laura.
We will be moving on to the next talk by Ruth.
And as y'all know there's also a second track.
We have talk by Jessica Tran, Hacking My Anxiety
with Open Source Technology.
So if you're interested in that, that's going
to be starting in five minutes, as well.
So who's interested in making an interactive
visual cool stuff happen with the web?
People into this.
Yeah, absolutely!
We're doing a lot of visual stuff that people
can access visually, and there's a lot of
space in the web area to do that.
And as a warning, there are going to be flashing
lights in this presentation, so anybody sensitive
to that, just to be aware.
And there's also going to be some sound playing.
And also with the accessibility talk, I really
like the term "spaces of empathy."
I think this is a really great term to talk
about being empathic with people and creating
a situation in which you can be empathic because
it's easy to lose that.
Do we have any, like, audio-visual artists
out there attending?
The setup looks really exciting.
I can't wait to see it.
Also, I'll bring this up again, but in the
Community Lounge, there's going to be talks
during the break, and also some of our sponsors
have workshops going on.
For example, I know the Mozilla table is going
to have a rust workshop if anybody is into
that, and later on, another one.
So make sure you check out those tables.
There's going to be stuff going on.
I'll bring it up again later when we go for
lunch.
Yeah?